hey there my name is Cameron welcome to
3d layer techniques these training
videos are a complement to the 3d camera
technique series so if you haven't
watched that series yet please do and
the next several videos you are going to
learn about 3d layers inside of After
Effects flat 2d motion design can look
great but adding 3d elements can make
motion design awesome so let's dive in
and get started
this is motion science
to make a 2d layer 3d the process is
simple go to the timeline and with the
selection tool click here
using the default classic render a 3d
layer remains flat but properties for Z
position anchor point scale orientation
and rotation all become active by
default 3d layers of AZ position value
of zero meaning that they stay centered
in the scene access modes help to orient
the 3d layer position and rotation and
after effects there are three axis modes
local aligns the x y and z axes to the
3d layer world mode aligns the axes to
the composition so no matter the changes
to a layers rotation the axes are always
relative to the composition and View
mode aligns the axes to the selected
view by placing a 3d camera in the scene
and moving around the axes will always
orient towards the camera view to
position or rotate the 3d layer on its
axes use the selection and rotation
tools found in the tools panel the
shortcut for selection is V and the
shortcut for rotation is W
3d layers can also be positioned or
rotated by going to the timeline panel
and directly inputting numbers for the
property values or by hovering over the
property clicking and dragging by
holding down the shift key while
dragging property values can change more
quickly to higher or lower values a pro
tip that is sometimes useful to control
orientation of 3d layers is to use the
auto orient function
go to layer transform Auto Orient and
choose orient along path when a layer
needs to follow a motion path or orient
towards camera when a layer needs to
always face the camera
material options specify how 3d layers
interact with lights and shadows to
access material options quickly with the
3d layer selected tap a a on the
keyboard the first material option casts
shadows enables a 3d layer to cast
shadows on other 3d layers the three
modes are off on and only only turns the
layer visibility off but the layer still
casts the shadow light transmission is
the amount of color from a 3d layer that
is cast as a shadow no light
transmission produces a dark black
shadow while a value of 100% light
transmission casts 100% of the layer
color onto the shadow accepts shadows
turns on the layers ability to receive
shadows from another 3d layer this
option can also be set to OFF on or only
only will act as a shadow catcher and
reveal the accepted shadow on the
transparent layer accepts lights enables
a 3d layer to accept lights within the
scene ambient is the non directional
reflectivity of the layer and is like
having a layer equally lit from all
directions diffuse is the Omni
directional reflectivity of the layer
the further away the layer is from a
light source the more darkness will
appear in the layer
specular intensity is the directional
reflectivity of the layer and how shiny
the layer appears specular shininess is
the size of the specular highlight and
glossiness of the reflection glossiness
can range from blurry to mere light and
metal is the contribution of the layer
color to the color of the specular
highlight a value of 100% metal means
that the highlight color is the color of
the layer
unlike 2d layers 3d layers interact with
shadows and lights After Effects uses
four types of lights that are similar to
real-world lights add a new light to the
composition by going to layer new light
or use the shortcut shift command Y
parallel lights emit directional light
from a very long distance
spotlights emit from a cone shape point
lights emit in all directions and
ambient lights emit with no light source
or shadow but add to the overall
luminance of a scene each of the four
light types have options intensity is
the brightness of the light intensity
can be both positive and negative
meaning it can add to or take away light
from a scene color determines the light
color a pro tip is to stay away from
100% white even slightly off white
lights can make a composition more
visually appealing
fall-off is how the lights intensity
lessens over a distance there are three
types the first none represents no
decrease in light intensity no matter
the distance that the light travels the
second smooth represents a linear
fall-off starting at the radius and
extending by the fall-off distance and
the third inverse-square clamped is a
physically accurate fall-off
starting at the radius and decreasing
proportionally the further away the
light gets radius is the area of
fall-off fall-off distance is the
distance the light falls from a light
source cast shadows is whether or not
the light casts a shadow on 3d layers
shadow darkness is how dark the shadow
appears point and spotlights have an
additional option for shadow softness
known as shadow diffusion and finally
spotlights add cone angle and feather
cone angle is the width size of the cone
opening and feather is the edge softness
of that opening
a pro tip is to adjust shadowmap
resolution for scenes using lights that
take too long to render or don't look
quality enough in the final render to
adjust shadow map resolution go to
composition composition settings 3d
render options from here a preset can be
selected to increase or decrease the
shadow map resolution
layer stacking within the timeline can
affect how 2d and 3d layers interact
with each other and how a final
composition will look normally one 3d
layer that is lit and stacked in front
of another 3d layer will cast a shadow
on the underneath layer but when a 2d
layer is inserted into the layer stack a
3d layer will not cast a shadow on any
other 3d layer that is on the other side
of the 2d layer in the stacking order
this also applies to 3d layer
intersections a pro tip is to place an
adjustment layer between the 3d layers
where the unwanted shadow or
intersection is seen the adjustment
layer is 2d but remains invisible and
the unwanted shadow or intersection will
disappear other types of layers can
break unwanted shadows and intersections
as well they are 3d layers with applied
layer styles 3d pre comps with applied
effects closed masks or track mats or 3d
pre comps without collapse
transformations
new to After Effects CC 2017 is the
cinema 4d rendering engine by using the
cinema 4d renderer a three layer inside
of After Effects can be bent beveled and
extruded to enable this renderer press
command K on the keyboard to open up
composition settings click on the 3d
renderer tab from here select cinema 4d
a list of enabled features and
limitations will appear please take the
time to read through them click on the
options tab the new quality slider is
meant to make it easy and take out the
guesswork and setting ray threshold
great depth reflection depth shadow
depth anti-aliasing and reflectance all
by just dragging left or right choose a
quality setting that has a good render
speed and acceptable image quality
before rendering always slide the
quality slider to the right to produce
the best image results for a final
render now to bend a 3d layer first
ensure that the selected layer is 3d in
the timeline then open up the geometry
options by twirling down this arrow note
that layer bending only works on
imported footage solid layers and pre
comps since layer bending does not work
on native text the solution is to pre
compose the text first
adjust the curvature between zero and
100% geometry segments determine how
many segments the curved layer is broken
into the default segment number is 4
double the number of segments until a
desired smoothness level is achieved
with the cinema 4d renderer 3d text and
shape layers can be beveled and extruded
Z depth is added by increasing extrusion
increase bevel and bevel hole depth to
give outer and inner edge depth slide
between values of 1 and 10 or directly
input a number above 10 for larger
bevels there are 4 bevel styles built-in
none angular concave and convex
additional material options for
reflections also become available when
using the cinema 4d renderer when
working with reflections footage and
nested pre comps can be used to
aspherical e mapped environment layers
to make interesting reflections to make
an environment layer choose layer
environment layer or right click on the
layer in the timeline the layer will
switch from 2d to 3d and a small globe
icon will appear next to its name
properties for orientation rotation and
transparency are all animatable appears
and reflections indicates if the current
3d layer appears in other layers
reflections reflection intensity
controls how much other reflective 3d
layers appear on the 3d layer reflection
sharpness controls the sharpness or
blurriness of reflections reflection
roll-off controls the amount of fernell
effect which is the intensity of
reflections at certain angles a pro tip
is to slightly vary materials on
different surfaces so that each surface
is not exactly the same this can make
compositions more visually appealing to
do this technique open up the shape
properties located next to contents
click on the arrow for add the different
side options for front bevel side and
back are available here on text layers
these options can be found in the
properties under the animate arrow
in the Irate race 3d renderer a 3d layer
has the same geometry options as found
in the cinema 4d renderer bending
beveling and extrusions
but the raytrace renderer produces a
slightly different look to enable this
renderer press command K on the keyboard
to open up composition settings click on
the 3d renderer tab from here select
raytrace 3d a list of features and
limitations similar to the cinema 4d
renderer will appear take the time to
read through these as well a pro tip is
to use the cinema 4d renderer whenever
possible it is faster than the rate race
renderer a second pro tip to maximize
workflow while using the raytrace
renderer is to set the composition panel
preview mode to direct this setting is
the equivalent of setting a rate raise
quality to 1 in composition settings but
be aware of limitations with shadows and
reflections material options for the
raytrace render are the same as the
cinema 4d render with 2 added options
transparency and environment layer
options transparency controls the
materials transparency surfaces can be
fully transparent the still show
reflections and specular highlights like
scene and glass transparency roll off
controls the amount of transparency
relative to the viewing angle on a
transparent surface and index of
refraction controls how light bends and
distorts through 3d layers with a value
of 1 equaling no distortion and a value
of 5 equalling solid glass or water when
using environment layers with the
raytrace renderer an option for appears
and reflections will be enabled this
controls how the environment map is used
in the scene set to on the environment
appears both in reflective objects and
as a backdrop
set to only the environment appears only
in reflective objects and set to OFF the
environment appears only as a backdrop
to the scene a pro tip is to use the
effect stylize cz repet I'll whenever
seams are visible in the reflection this
effect helps to blend seams
cinah where is a powerful tool it
enables 3d layers to have even more
advanced shapes bevels and textures
because 3d layers are built inside of
cinema 4d by composited and rendered
inside of After Effects a version of
cinema 4d comes packaged with After
Effects CC with sin aware After Effects
can import any pre-built cinema 4d
project or export any composition
directly to cinema 4d to import a cinema
4d project go to file import and import
the file make a new composition by going
to composition new composition and drag
the cinema 4d file from the project
window into the composition the cinah
where effect is automatically added and
can be found in the effects panel to
edit the cinema 4d file select the file
in the timeline and go to edit edit
original cinema 4d will launch make any
necessary changes inside a cinema 4d and
then save the file in After Effects the
cinema 4d file is automatically updated
to synchronize time lines between cinema
4d and After Effects enable Livelink
render settings control how the image
looks and tells after effects which
cinema 4d renderer to use the camera is
selected under project settings choose
from baked in cameras in the cinema 4d
file
a new centered comp camera in After
Effects for an existing After Effects
camera already in the timeline cinema 40
layers Wynn checked allow four layers to
be on or off
within the cinema 45 this means a cinema
4d file could turn on or off 3d elements
internally by duplicating the cinema 4d
file and setting each of these layers to
show individual elements compositing
becomes easier because of the ability to
stack layers
multipass image layers enables specific
compositing layers to be extracted into
After Effects and lastly commands
extracts cinema 4d scene data directly
into After Effects
this can include cameras lights and
position data from external compositing
tags in this series we explored how to
enable and control 3d layers how to work
with lights and shadows how to utilize
material options and how to take
advantage of the advanced renderers and
settings now that you know the
techniques to master 3d layers inside of
After Effects it's time to put that
knowledge into practice download the
free After Effects project file below
and explore how I use different 3d layer
techniques to build it practice makes
perfect and the more you practice the
better you will become as a motion
designer I would love to hear your
thoughts about this training series and
what you would like to see in future
series so please leave a comment below
thanks for taking the time to watch and
until next time I'm Cameron and this is
motion science
you